So let's see Java RMI at work. On
the server side, it's a three-step process to make
the server object visible on the network. You
instantiate the object. Once you instantiate the object, you
create a URL, whatever you want to call the URL. And then you go to the Java run
time, and the facility that's available in the Java
run time For binding the URL that you created
with the instance of the object that
you created. The object that you instantiated;
it binds it to this URL and it is now in the naming service
of the Java runtime system. For clients to be able to discover the existence
of this new service that you created and made it available on the network.